all the lives lost and disrupted are
hard to take in one of the hardest hit
places in ukraine is the northern city
of cherniv amnesty international says an
airstrike in early march involved at
least eight unguided bombs that
indiscriminately hit civilians the city
played a key role in preventing russian
troops from advancing into the capital
kiev
russia has since retreated from the area
our europe bureau chief crystal
gamansing got a firsthand look at what
was left behind
some scars of war are obvious charred
buildings with gaping holes and
shattered glass
others are buried deep inside survivors
at the time of the explosion i was very
close to the place ighor markovic
recalls hearing the roar of an airplane
engine and seeing it fly low he didn't
need to explain what he saw next instead
he showed us his phone and a video
transporting us back two months to march
3rd
[Music]
the chaos the sound of people screaming
the bodies on the ground the images are
hard to watch but ihor
lived it
see the line here at the place where
they are standing now
you can see the leg was blown off
amnesty international says up to eight
unguided bombs were dropped here killing
at least 47 people human rights watch
was unable to identify any legitimate
military targets in the area and
concluded this strike could constitute a
warcraft
i don't see any logic in this wall
except to destroy and kill people
[Music]
at saint catherine's cathedral
worshipers share prayers to keep those
on the front lines safe and their
families at home supported
chernihev was besieged for weeks it
looked bleak there was no power no water
or food
700 deaths here have been directly
linked to the war
and those are just the ones that show
obvious signs of trauma
yuri pollock has worked for more than 20
years in forensics and has never
experienced anything like it
most of my friends do not believe what
happened in our country and want to wake
up on 21st of february in peace they
have never seen such things even in
nightmares
the last of the invading russian forces
retreated in april but for survivors the
pain is still palpable
crystal gomansen global news chinese
ukraine